The new trailer for Pet Sematary suggests
one major change from the novel and one major
change from the 1989 movie.
If you haven’t seen trailer #2 yet -- I’d
recommend not watching it, you can just watch
this Things You Missed video, and I’ll tell
you when to leave if you want to avoid spoilers.
Deal?
Deal.
Let’s roll the intro.
So the trailer opens with the mother of the
family, Rachel, telling her husband that their
daughter Ellie discovered a “charming landmark”
in woods and then it shows Ellie wandering
around the Pet Sematary by herself.
This is not how it goes down in the book at
all.
In the book, their neighbor Jud Crandall takes
the entire Creed family to the Pet Sematary
to introduce them to the woods behind their
house.
Maybe that does still happen, because we do
see both of them there together later in the
trailer, and trailers have been known to lie
to us in the past.
But when we do see Ellie supposedly arriving
at the Pet Sematary, there’s a little picture
frame in the bottom right corner with a photo
of a parrot.
When they first visit the Pet Sematary in
the book, Ellie’s father, Louis, notices
a grave plot labeled Polynesia and thinks
to himself that Polynesia would have been
a parrot if he remembered his Dr. Doolittle
correctly and would have squaked her last
“Polly want a cracker” in the summer of
1953.
King also describes Polynesia’s grave when
Louis returns to the burial ground towards
the end of the book and when he steps over
the ragged chunk of board that marks Polynesia’s
final resting place; it kind of represents
him going past the land of the dead.
Also, if you go frame by frame while the headstones
are flashing on screen, you can read this
one, labeled Trixie, kilt on the highway,
which is also one of the grave markers Louis
reads when first visiting the Pet Sematary
in the book, where he also sees the death
date September 15, 1968.
So I think it’s pretty cool that they’re
referencing some of the Pet Sematary animal
inhabitants in the movie, nice little easter
eggs.
One thing that’s included in the movie that
is not in the book is this mask left on one
of the graves, and these kids wearing the
masks as they parade their deceased pets to
the sematary.
There is a story that Jud Crandall passes
down in the book about how the kids would
bring their pets down the forest path to the
sematary.
Sometimes the pet owner would go alone, like
when Jud buried his dog Spot, and sometimes
they would have more of a funeral procession
type of thing, I specifically remember Jud
telling of an argument between two kids back
in the day getting into a debate about who
got to hold onto the casket.
But the animal masks and instruments were
never a part of the book.
There are some things that were mentioned
in the book, but after being absent from the
80s film have returned for the new adaptation.
Let’s roll the clip.
“It’s not some campfire story.”
“Saw these in the trees up there.”
“They’re warnings.
The local tribes carved them before they fled.”
Louis researches the spiral in this book called
Modern History of Eastern Native Tribes.
The caption here says, “The pictograph of
the spiral was found carved into the trees
of the forests of Maine, As a warning to others,
or a way of warding off the evil spirit.”
What is this evil spirit?
It’s right there: the Wendigo, an Algonquian
mythological creature.
(In the case of Pet Sematary it’s referred
to as a Micmac legend).
The Wendigo has ties to cannibalism and greed
in times of famine and resides in the northeast
region of the US.
Some versions of the legend say a human who
craves another man’s flesh is cursed to
become a Wendigo, but the Wendigo in Stephen
King’s novel is more of a deity who stalks
the ground of Ludlow, Maine where the story
takes place.
Jud tells Louis that the Micmac tribe stopped
using their burial ground, because the ground
had been “soured” by the Wendigo.
He also blames the Wendigo for causing bad
things to happen in the town, telling Louis
he believes that Wendigo possessed him to
show Louis the Micmac burial ground.
Legend has it that if the creature touches
you, it can turn you into a cannibal.
The pictures shown in the trailer show off
the Wendigo’s cannibalistic side and it’s
form which matches the typical depiction of
the Wendigo with a human body capped by the
head or horns of a stag.
The spiral is also mentioned in the book,
but it’s more of a sign of the Wendigo’s
intervention and introduction of ideas that
go against nature.
When Louis visits Pleasantview Cemetery, he
finds himself thinking about the graves at
the Pet Sematary.
He refers to the spiral as the oldest sign
of power in the world.
Man’s oldest symbol of that twisty bridge
that may exist between the world and the gulf.
Louis finds himself absentmindedly drawing
a spiral pattern in the dirt while he is thinking
and erases it before leaving.
Then, later on, when he returns to the burial
ground, he notices that the rocks have fallen
in such a way as to give to appearance of
a gigantic spiral, giving us the idea that
a greater presence is at work.
On one of the other pages of the book, someone
has drawn in their own spiral and a pentagram,
I’m guessing Louis finds his hands drawing
in these symbols without realizing just as
he drew the spiral on the dirt in the book.
Jud Crandall is seen wearing a hat throughout
several scenes of the trailer that says LeVett
Motor Oil.
This might be an oil company based near Fort
LeVett in Maine, which is named after Christopher
LeVett, one of the early settlers of the New
England area.
I think Jud wearing this hat means that he
represents the white man laying down a path
into Native American territory that they have
no business meddling in.
Jud is the one to show Louis how to get to
the Mic Mac burial ground and introduce him
to the power it holds.
Native American curses are a common theme
in Stephen King’s stories.
And speaking of King’s writing, it looks
like there’s a little reference to Carrie,
with a hand reaching out of the ground and
grabbing Louis’s arm.
And that’s not something from the book,
so I’d guess it’s part of Louis’s dream.
One thing that was not shown in the first
trailer that has been revealed here in the
second one is Zelda, Rachel’s sister who
passed away when they were young from severe
spinal meningitis.
The thought of Zelda haunts Rachel for the
rest of her life and she even has visions
of her as an adult, which appears to be what’s
going on in this scene and it looks pretty
horrifying.
We also get a better look at Louis’s encounter
with Victor Pascow, a University student that
dies under Louis’s care during his first
day of work and tries to warn him about the
evil that lies beyond the Pet Sematary.
In the book he was hit by a car while out
jogging.
It looks like they’ve changed things up
a bit in this new movie, because he’s not
wearing running shorts and something is sticking
out of his neck, can’t really tell what.
I don’t know why this change was made, and
that kind of leads me to my next point, however,
if you don’t want any spoilers this is the
end of the line for you.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Go watch this video.
If you’re still here, you may have already
thought what I’m thinking: that Pascow’s
injury seems to just be changed for change’s
sake.
We won’t know for sure until we see the
movie, but as of right now it certainly seems
that way.
You’ve probably also noticed that the trailer
seems to suggest that Ellie is going to be
the one struck down by the truck, as opposed
to her brother Gage.
Like I said before, trailers do lie sometimes,
but it does seem like Ellie is seen running
into the road before the truck comes, there
are Ellie sized footprints on the stairs,
and Ellie tracks mud into the house and horrifies
her mother with her appearance.
Then and as Rachel is watching over Gage,
something pops up and scares her, and it appears
to be Ellie.
At the end of the trailer, a girl with a cat
mask attacks Jud, which may or may not be
Ellie, but a lot of signs seem to point to
her being the one Louis has to bury in the
cursed burial ground.
So why was this changed in the remake?
In my personal opinion, this would have been
a fun change if it had been for shock value.
Fans of the originals would go into the movie
expecting it to be Gage who is killed, making
it that much more shocking when Ellie is unexpectedly
struck down.
But now that they’ve gone and spoiled it
in the trailer... that won’t be the case
at all -- which makes me think it’s just
another example of change for the sake of
change.
Maybe there is some reason that the roles
of Ellie and Gage are flipped in the film,
and I won’t make my final judgements until
I have seen the movie, but if they are just
changing it for no reason, then some of the
brilliance of the story is going to be lost.
For example, the contrast between Louis’s
first trip, where he struggles to carry Gage
in the baby backpack and his second trip where
he easily carries Gage’s corpse in the middle
of the night is going to be lost because it’s
not like he’ll be carrying Ellie during
the first trip in the movie.
And the psychological trauma Gage’s death
puts on Ellie won’t be there with Gage in the movie,
because he’s just not old enough to fully
comprehend it like Ellie would have.
We will just have to wait and see how everything
shakes out, but let me know what you think
of these changes so far and make sure you’re
subscribed to CZsWorld and ring the deathbell
so you don’t miss out on Things You Missed
episodes on the the 1989 Pet Sematary, it’s
sequel and more Pet Sematary related content
coming soon to this channel.
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.